it's Thanksgiving and you know what that
means pumpkin pie and mashed potatoes
and a bunch of insufferable leftist
think pieces
preparing liberals to suffer the torture
of speaking to a single conservative
even once even when they're related to
even for just a couple hours however
however can we possibly expect liberals
to talk to their crazy Republican
articles at the dinner table well as a
crazy right-wing uncle myself we will
examine how liberals talk about talking
to us then president Trump pardons
turkeys and CNN spreads lies about our
brave forefathers who sailed on the
Mayflower and found in America we will
correct the Thanksgiving record and as
if Thanksgiving weren't hard enough for
her already
laia waffle is war and gets some bad
polling news heading into the holiday
all that and more I'm Michael Knowles
and this is the Michael Nolt show
[Music]
how are they gonna do it how are our
poor left-wing relatives possibly going
to endure the torture and suffering of
having to speak to conservative
relatives at the Thanksgiving table that
is the question posed by left-wing
outlets every single year this year from
AlterNet how to talk impeachment with
your right-wing uncle over the holidays
that's me by the way they're right that
entire pieces about me
the independent how to deal with your
Trump loving uncle this holiday season
MarketWatch is from MarketWatch opinion
how to win every economic and political
argument with your family this
Thanksgiving now Market Watch in their
headline they try to make it seem like
it's balanced like it could go either
for the left or for the right but then
you read the article you realize it's
all just about how to deal with your
crazy conservative uncle it's all just
about how to refute right-wing arguments
say also from MarketWatch how to talk
about the economy with your family at
Thanksgiving same thing it seems like
it's balance but it's actually just
about how to refute conservatives that
peace begins if your uncle corners you
at Thanksgiving dinner you know quarters
you like all us conservative uncle's do
and starts talking about how the US
economy is the best it's ever been what
should you do how should you respond
beyond the think pieces Bernie Sanders
himself has some advice on how to deal
with your conservative uncle at
Thanksgiving if you are going home and
getting nervous about arguing with you
mommy you're dead or you're on to your
uncle
I think the point to be made is that
what we are fighting for the values that
we are fighting for are really not new
values I mean they go back literally
thousands of years the right that we
treat each other the way we want to be
treated that's what we want to do we
want to treat each other the way that we
want to be treated but it's it's all the
thing about the premise of this the
premise is you're nervous about talking
to your mom or your dad or your uncle
because they might be conservative and
you've never talked to any conservative
so how on earth are you possibly going
to do that well you've got it's so so
important how about in the past from the
LA Times what to do if you're crazy
right-wing uncle comes to Thanksgiving
what to do if he comes to Thanksgiving
you're hoping
the conservative relatives don't even
show up they're not even expected in
polite society they shouldn't be here at
all but if they do you got to deal with
that you got to deal with having a
relative who has a different political
view than yours here's how you can talk
to him
Salon magazine how to argue with
right-wing relatives how to argue with
them that's what Thanksgiving is all
about is picking fights with your
right-wing relatives Mother Jones you
won't change your cranky conservative
uncle in one dinner conversation that
old crank you know that old cranky
conservative New York Times how to have
a conversation with your crazy uncle
over the holidays our conservatives
really the angry ones here are
conservatives really the crazy ones the
crazed ones because if I if I all I had
to go on we're just those headlines from
all those newspapers and magazines and
Bernie Sanders if that's all I had to go
on I would say it's actually the
leftists that are the angry ones I would
say the only people who seem crazed here
or the left wingers you'll notice that
you never see articles the other way
around I have seen it scores if not
hundreds of articles probably hundreds
that say how to deal with your crazy
Republican uncle I don't know that I've
ever seen an article that says how to
deal with your crazy liberal niece if it
may be one or two maybe I don't even
have any recollection of that it only
goes in one direction it's advice for
liberals on how to deal with their
conservative relatives and it always
describes the conservative relatives as
crazed and angry but that's because the
Left projects whatever's true of them
they project unto others why all the
articles why do the articles only go in
one direction they need the articles
because they actually can't refute our
arguments we will get into this a little
bit more we'll get into the real studies
whether or not people fight over the
Thanksgiving dinner table on politics
first I've got to thank our friends over
at last coat let me tell you I live in
LA so it doesn't rain here a whole lot
when it does rain it is like the
floodgates are opening and it's
it's like I'm Noah in the ark very
important especially this time of year
to protect your car from water from dirt
we got a lot of that in LA from salt we
get a lot of that from the Sun we get a
lot of that all of these things can
combine and rot away your car you know
you just don't want that it doesn't look
good it's not good for the car that's
why I want to tell you about the last
coat it is a proprietary versatile and
durable all-in-one easy to use all
surface do-it-yourself coating that
gives car is a slick mirror-like finish
in minutes it looks so good
also it's very good for glass vinyl
leather stainless steel counter tops
electronic screens you know that black
mirror most fabrics a lot more it's it's
an unbelievable product it's also a
great gift idea especially for that car
lover in the family you know sometimes
it's a little hard to pick out a gift
for dad or for uncle maybe your crazy
uncle at the dinner table this thing is
so great
almost certainly they don't have it they
you know this is a pretty pretty new
technology it creates a protective shell
on your car that protects the car from
UV rays road salt abrasive soaps extreme
temperatures which happens a lot around
this time of year and more the
protection encoding lasts for up to six
months got thousands of five-star
reviews online so you don't just need to
take my word for it 100% made in the USA
365 day money-back guarantee and for a
limited time my listeners get a 25%
discount on a 16 ounce bottle of the
last coat it is the most durable all
surface do-it-yourself coating
technology on the market get the best
for reference an average sized car only
takes one or two ounces for full
coverage it's amazing stuff take
advantage of the 25% discount go to
Latvia last koat.com slash Noel's canna
wles then once you get there type in
Noel's 25 at checkout that is the last
coat comm slash Knowles type in nulls 25
at checkout to get 25% off the last coat
is a great gift idea for the car
enthusiasts in your family the last coat
comm slash Knowles
Knowles 25 a check out take full
advantage of this limited time offer why
do leftists need all of these think
pieces why do they need help
talking to their conservative uncle at
the dinner table the reason is they
don't know how to refute our arguments
we don't need articles about how to talk
to leftists cuz we talked to leftists
all the time we've talked to leftists
every single day in corporate America at
the University when we get go to the
movies when we go watch TV when we read
the newspaper we are aware of left-wing
arguments if we persist in our
conservatism it's because we've answered
them we know how to refute them the Left
doesn't do that and actually moreover
the left needs the articles because they
don't even understand our arguments they
don't know what our arguments are John
hight the social scientist did a study
if number of years ago which showed that
conservatives generally speaking
understand liberal arguments but
liberals do not understand conservative
arguments they just don't really get
where we're coming from and so to the
left we seem cranky and crazy and angry
it just doesn't make any sense to them
therefore they can read these articles
and try to figure out at least some way
how to even grasp what we're getting at
obviously they're not gonna do a very
good job at refuting our arguments
that's why they need a new article every
single year but then the question is why
bring it up at all who wants to talk
about politics at the Thanksgiving
dinner table these hardcore leftists
have to talk about politics at the
dinner table because they don't have
religion what is Thanksgiving we'll get
into the history of Thanksgiving in a
second Thanksgiving is when you come
together as a family and you give thanks
to God for all of the blessings that you
share the first Thanksgiving was shared
by the Native American Indians in
America and the pilgrims who came from
England through litem to Plymouth and
they were giving thanks to God these
were Christian zealots for all the
blessings that they had that's what we
are recreating every year on
Thanksgiving the left doesn't have
traditional religion and so for the left
politics is religion and so just as we
would practice our Christian religion at
the Thanksgiving table and give thanks
to God and to Providence and just enjoy
all the blessings we have so to the left
must
proselytize their own false and
political religion but despite all the
left-wing think pieces it turns out most
people don't get into fights at the
Thanksgiving dinner table over politics
there was a study that came out just a
couple years ago huffington post YouGov
survey showed that do you know how many
Americans say that they get into fights
at the dinner table three percent three
percent of Americans say that it is very
likely that they will get into a
political fight at the Thanksgiving
dinner table eight percent say it's
somewhat likely that's it that's all
three percent at the most eight percent
most of us are having a good time but
the people who are not having a good
time the people who are getting into
these fights are the most hardcore
leftists who write at AlterNet and the
New York Times and the LA Times
Huffington Post very sorry for them very
sad sort of state of affairs for for
that but the rest of us are gonna have a
very good Thanksgiving speaking of a
good Thanksgiving you know I caught a
little bit of flack yesterday because I
opposed president Trump's decision to
turn animal cruelty from a state crime
to a federal crime and I have posted on
Federalist grounds and I just thought it
was kind of an inverted way to look at
the moral order so I caught some flak
people said I don't like animals well
let me tell you something I'm a big fan
of animals especially the ones I get to
eat at the Thanksgiving table but I
actually support President Trump's
decision yesterday to have some leniency
on animals and to pardon the -
Thanksgiving turkeys bread and butter he
did an absolute great job at the pardon
here he is thankfully bread and butter
have been specially raised by the
Jacksons to remain calm under any
condition which will be very important
because they've already received
subpoenas to appear in Adam shifts
basement on Thursday true
hundreds of people have it seems the
Democrats are accusing me of being too
soft on Turkey but bread and butter I
should note that unlike previous
witnesses you and I have actually met
it's very unusual very unusual in any
event I expect this pardon will be a
very popular one with the media after
all turkeys are closely related to a
vultures I don't know if I like that
line but there is a little truth to it I
love him I just love him I was I can't
help it when he does things like that I
just love the guy even down to he's got
all these lines right they making fun of
Adam shift making fun of the whole
impeachment inquiry how at least he's
met the turkeys unlike most of the other
witnesses and then he gets that last
line about the media being like vultures
and that classic show business of Trump
kicks in he says I don't know if I like
that line that's a little bit weak but
whatever I guess it's true
he's just so what you see is what you
get it's so authentic really funny great
way to use the turkey pardoning
tradition so I not only support the
pardon for the turkeys for these turkeys
bread and butter I do support the the
tradition overall we'll get into a
little bit of how that started what it
means why it's great for politics then
so much more to get to on the history of
Thanksgiving first I got to thank our
friends over at movement I knew that it
was time to get to this because I have a
very sleek movement watch Black Friday
is here and movement watches are having
the biggest sale of the year for a
limited time only every single thing at
MVM t.com movement calm is on sale
that's hundreds of premium watches blue
light glasses sunglasses jewelry styles
with a fresh new discount just in time
for the holidays and all of your
gift-giving needs I will tell you last
year I bought all sorts of presents for
my family and luckily because we've got
a good good partnership with movement I
was able to get a discount on some
movement products so I got two watches
got a couple watches for my family I
gave
watch to my father last year I thought
okay we'll see you know you like the
show hopefully you like the watch I
obviously like my watch
this was the best gift I gave all year
it went over so well because it's a
fabulous gift you know movement watches
are designed in house
they are extremely sleek clean they
won't break the bank
I've gotten more comments on my movement
watch than any other watch I've ever
owned same thing is true of my dad same
things to have other family members
movement watches are an affordable
option clean design minimal really
really high quality stuff movement has
sold almost 2 million watches in over
160 countries 2 million people can't be
wrong shop their biggest sale of the
year right now at MVM t.com use code
holiday 19 at checkout and get free
shipping and free returns by going to
MVM t-dot-com code holiday 19 trust me
you are gonna be a hero this holiday
season with a movement MVM t.com join
the movement
so Trump pardon the turkey part of a
great tradition this began the turkey
pardoning at the White House began
actually as part of a lobbying campaign
well over half a century ago because the
Truman administration wanted to conserve
resources so they were promoting
meatless Tuesday's and poultry lists
Thursday's that last one doesn't really
roll off the tongue does it could have
done meatless Mondays that at least has
alliteration but they didn't meatless
Tuesday's poll treeless thursdays and
poultry list thursdays coincides with
thanksgiving so people were very upset
so the industry in 1947 presented truman
with a turkey as a gift to promote the
industry now this didn't technically
begin the turkey pardon tradition
because truman did not pardon the turkey
he killed the turkey and cooked it and
ate it because back in those days
Americans were real men
JFK them well actually Eisenhower then
continued the tradition so Eisenhower
continued the tradition of receiving the
turkeys he also did not pardon them he
ate the delicious turkeys you get to JFK
JFK Democrat started the tradition of
not eating the turkey in 1963
interestingly he pardoned the first
turkey he didn't call it a pardon but he
decided not to eat it for days before
his own assassination and that was the
beginning of this trend but it was not a
pardon because what JFK did was he took
the bird sent it back to the farm and he
said quote we'll let this one grow so it
wasn't a poor it was a reprieve so that
he could fatten the turkey up more and
eat it next year unfortunately he never
had the chance to then Nixon
administration comes along
Nixon let a few turkeys go then Carter
refused to even accept the turkeys he
was so hoity-toity he thought it was a
ridiculous tradition he wouldn't even
accept the gift the first president to
pardon a turkey the Gipper good old
Ronald Reagan he obviously had a good
relationship with the animal kingdom he
was friends with Bonzo from that
wonderful movie bedtime for Bonzo so he
let the turkey go and this was all show
business just like you saw with
President Trump Trump uses the turkey
pardon and the media circus around him
to push his agenda on impeachment
Reagan's started that tradition that
show business tradition by using the
turkey pardoned to take attention off of
the iran-contra scandal this was in 1987
I guess and he joked about the turkey
pardon because there was a question over
whether he would pardon Oliver North
during that time so he he used a sort of
light-hearted part him to take attention
off of that so Reagan importance the
turkey Bush one enjoyed the turkey
pardoning tradition Clinton pardoned a
couple turkeys and then since Bush to
Bush Obama and Trump they've all
pardoned a turkey every single year I
think it's great I love the tradition
you know I tend to be a little
old-school I like things that are old
more than things that are new I think
modernity is really rotting out Society
but sometimes traditions grow over time
and the newer idea is better than the
older idea I love the idea of pardoning
of Turkey once a year it's one way to
come together in politics and not just
be shrill and angry all the time and get
a few good digs in at your political
opponents not everybody loves
Thanksgiving unfortunately I love it
because I'm an American
four of my ancestors sailed on the
Mayflower one of them was a pilgrim I
love the holiday CNN doesn't love it
a left doesn't love it CNN actually ran
a piece about how everything we think we
know about Thanksgiving is wrong and how
actually the leftist revisionist history
is right and what they're banking on is
that nobody knows the actual history of
Thanksgiving but they're wrong because
I've been very interested in the history
of Thanksgiving for most of my life it's
not just CNN I mean various universities
have been teaching classes on this and
in recent weeks
here is the revisionist history being
pushed by CNN let's see why it's wrong
about our forefathers on the Mayflower
most of American history depicted
hospitable first Thanksgiving 1621
grateful pilgrims in the new world offer
a warm invitation to assume equal and
members of his Wampanoag tribe but the
chairman of the Mashpee Wampanoag calls
that depiction a myth you know we sent
90 men over to the first settlers to see
why they were shooting guns and practice
in arms to say hey what are you
preparing for and they were preparing
for some kind of war to take our people
down and so we sat down with them to
have a discussion and let their let it
feast
none of that is true none of those four
I also loved the whole idea we sent our
people over to the Mayflower I don't
know did we send our people over to
Plymouth from Leiden I don't know I
don't think so we're talking about
historical experiences and what they're
setting up here that what CNN and this
speaker is setting up here is the idea
that the the natives were so terrified
they were so afraid they were just
trying anything to broker a peace but
then pilgrims wouldn't give them a peace
and it was a tense fraught Thanksgiving
total BS not true the Wampanoag Indians
allied with the English intentionally
and out of their own interest actually
without the English there would have
been no such thing as the Wampanoag
nation so our best ally that we had our
best ally when we sailed on the
Mayflower and landed at Plymouth the the
best ally of the Englishman was a
Pokanoket sachem named masa soin nasa so
it was a Pokanoket and his tribe had
been devastated by smallpox in years
before that when the English arrived
NASA so it sent Squanto Squanto
was a Pawtuxet Indian who was being held
as prisoner by masa so had he sent
Squanto to help broker an alliance
why did Massa so at send Squanto because
Squanto talked about the hand of
Providence on the sailing of the
Mayflower and the founding of America
Squanto was possibly the only Native
American in the entire western
hemisphere to have a command of the
English language why is that because
Swan toe had lived in Spain and England
and he had been captured by by explorers
brought to Spain he was as a slave in
Spain Franciscan monks bought Squanto
freed Squanto almost certainly baptized
him a Catholic which is very funny that
a Catholic Indian would be the one to
help save the Puritan pilgrims story for
another time he's freed they then put
him on a ship get him to London
Squanto lived in London actually talked
with the pilgrims about the various
streets of London sails back to the new
world somehow hops a ship and makes it
back to his old people the Patuxent the
Pawtuxet tribe is totally wiped out he
makes it down to the Pocono cat masses
so it he's then held captive there and
then the pilgrims land at Plymouth
accidentally they were trying to sail to
Manhattan they get blown off-course they
land exactly where the only Indian who
speaks English fluently who is a
Catholic who understands their religion
and their native country happens to be
and Squanto brokers a piece if you don't
believe in Providence because of that I
don't know what other evidence I could
possibly show you but Squanto brokering
that peace was a huge advantage to Massa
so Abbey's masa so it and the the
Pokanoket Indians were not just some
helpless victims here they were not
being just absolutely destroyed and
oppressed by the English masses so it
used the English to his own advantage he
created an alliance to help him oppose
the Narragansett Indians and he actually
established through that alliance with
the English the Wampanoag nation that
this guy on CNN is pretending was a
victim of the English pilgrims the
Wampanoag nation would not have existed
without the English how did the peace
break down how will CNN try to break
down the history we'll get to that
first I got to think our friends over at
expressvpn you know hackers are not just
going after media companies like ours
like The Daily wire ok it's not just
these big companies they are going after
everyone who has their data on the
internet expressvpn is the software that
I and thousands of my fans use to
protect our data online in the time
since I started using expressvpn just
just in that period of time hacking
methods have grown more sophisticated so
at the Daily wire we put a lot of money
into cyber security all right and that's
because we are regularly the target of
attacks we have a whole IT department
right how about for an individual
Internet user for an individual Internet
user
you don't need an IT department to
protect you from online threats you
almost certainly couldn't have your own
IT department but what you do need what
will protect you is expressvpn I've been
talking about expressvpn on my show for
so long you probably already understand
why encrypting your network data is so
important some of you still have not
acted why not well it's probably because
you think like I used to think security
threats don't affect you personally but
they do not using expressvpn it's like
leaving your front door unlocked every
time you go out sure yeah nothing might
happen for years and years but when that
break-in does happen it is absolutely
devastating and listen if you're
listening to the show right now you
probably look at some pretty
questionable material on the Internet in
that old incognito window you know what
I'm talking about daily wire comm one of
the easiest ways to secure your Internet
data is with expressvpn click one button
on your computer your smart phone you
are protected from bad actors who want
your information it's absolutely
terrific absolutely essential get
expressvpn comm right now with my
special link expressvpn comm / michael
mi CH AE l you get an extra three months
of protection for free protect your
internet today with the VPN that I trust
to keep my data safe go to expressvpn
comm slash michael mi CH AE l to get
started so unlike what CNN is telling
you unlike what the leftists are telling
you the first interaction of the English
with the Native Americans is
quite fruitful it's quite an important
Alliance actually the piece that they
had brokered almost broke down it almost
broke down because the English were too
nice to Squanto masses so it wanted to
recapture and and kill Squanto the
English protected Squanto from being
killed by masses so it this almost
destroyed their alliance but it survived
and then by the way the pilgrims saved
massa so it's life to some masses so it
would have died in 1623
because he became very very ill he was
on his deathbed the pilgrims to save
their friend Massa so it sent edward
winslow Winslow's went to visit him
masses so it called out this is recorded
with great trustworthiness
he called out is it Winslow Winslow I
shall never see you again
so Winslow comes in the guise on his
deathbed he can he can barely speak he's
losing his sight and Winslow gave him
some Western medicine he then scraped
out massa so it's a mouth and he made
him a chicken broth after a few days
Massa recovered as thanks for this massa
so it told the pilgrims that the
Massachusetts Indians were going to
attack them and they were going to
attack the English colony of West gusset
so as a result of this Myles Standish of
the Plymouth Colony and Massa so its
forces United fought off the
Massachusetts Indians and expanded Massa
so its power considerably and saved the
English colonies you know the left-wing
history of this makes it seems like the
Indians were just like these helpless
children they weren't they were real
people they were real adults they had
real political strategies that worked
out very well with the pilgrims CNN goes
on some elders say the so-called first
Thanksgiving is not worth celebrating
it's the one day out of the year all of
America gives thanks for everything that
was taken from us 83 year old tall oaks
Rhode Island home is an archive of
Native American history
amongst the books and pictures and
relics as a copy of a 1970 speech
written by his late friend Wamsutta this
is what we were talking about yesterday
the difference between an attitude
toward the world of entitlement and an
attitude toward the world of gratitude
of duty of obligation
obviously the the people making the CNN
hit have no idea about the real history
of the Mayflower or the real history of
those early days but even consider the
the silly understanding of history to
say today is a terrible day Thanksgiving
is an awful memory and the way that we
commemorate this awful memory when the
Indians lost everything and the pilgrims
gained everything is we read about it in
books there wouldn't be any books
without the English settlers there
wouldn't be any American history the
person who's saying this would not be
speaking in English there would be no
television there would be no world as we
see it this is not to excuse everything
the English did this is not to vilify
the Native Americans this is not to
excuse periods of history this is to
point out that history is complicated
the history we're living right now the
history that our ancestors lived four
hundred years ago and to just sit and
whine that history happened is absurd I
mean it is ridiculous it is laughable
that is a surefire way to live a
miserable life in fact the way that that
CNN is describing this is that it was
the beginning of the end
we the wampa not once at a rote welcome
to you the white man with open arms
little knowing that it was the beginning
of the end he said he wasn't going to
change it and so he withdrew from that
and one said it tall oak and other
activists of the American Indian
Movement created their own event for the
following Thanksgiving Day we decided
that we would declare it a national day
of mourning for Native people how
disrespectful to those Indians to the
the Wampanoags and masa so it to suggest
that they were just these naive idiots
who didn't understand that various
different peoples might have interests
in the new world it's not that he just
mesozoic welcomed the pilgrims with open
arms it's that he created a strategic
alliance an alliance that endured for
generations afterward and that actually
was only broken by the Native American
Indians and this is where they get to
their real point the leftists always
drive this point home it has no basis in
the reality of the pilgrim experience
they call the history of Thanksgiving
genocide we're still fighting with our
very own trustee who we had treaties
with that we agreed to have a
relationship back in the 1700s and we're
still fighting that fight today to have
our lands
this Thanksgiving tall oak the only
surviving co-creator of the National Day
of Mourning hopes that you think less
about the natives contribution to a meal
nearly 400 years ago and more about as
the plaque on the monument reads the
genocide of millions of their people the
theft of their land and the relentless
assault on their culture it was a
terrible way to show you gratitude after
you've been given everything to make you
make it possible for you to survive
again completely fictitious history masa
so it died a friend of the pilgrims this
alliance between the Pilgrims and the
local Native Americans at least that
Wampanoags obviously not the
Massachusetts that the Wampanoags and
the pilgrims United to fight off the
massachusett or the Massachusetts rather
we weren't very good friends with but
this alliance between the Wampanoags and
pilgrims endured not just for masa so
its lifetime not just for squanto's
lifetime when Squanto died he said
please Englishman pray to me to your God
pray for me to your God your English God
he was a baptized Christian not just for
the lifetime of Meza so it's son
Alexander that's right masa so it gave
his son an English name a Christian name
it actually endured all the way through
to masa so it's grandson Philip and masa
so it's grandson Philip decided to wage
war on the English based on a
misunderstanding because he thought that
the English had killed one of his men he
actually the English had not done it
there was no historical evidence that
they did it and Philip waged a war that
was opposed by many many Native
Americans in the region and that war
permanently ruptured at the relationship
between the English and the Native
Americans in the region but that was a
that was a war waged by King Philip it's
called King Phillip's war you can look
it up you can read about it you're
definitely not going to hear about it on
CNN you're definitely not going to hear
about it in the mainstream media which
wants to obscure the real history of
Thanksgiving for which we should be all
of us exceedingly grateful
grateful not just for the wonderful
partnership between the Wampanoags and
the pilgrims not grateful merely for the
voyage of the Mayflower but but grateful
to our God that we have all of these
blessings since that that year in 1620
when the pilgrims sailed across the
ocean and began this American experiment
we've got a lot to get to before we get
to the mailbag I have got to point out
some really good news that the president
should be thankful for and conservatives
should be thankful for going into
Thanksgiving there's new testimony that
was released on the Ukraine issue on the
Ukraine phone call that's apparently
going to get this president kicked out
if the Democrats have their way a mark
sandy who worked at the Office of
Management and Budget under President
Trump was told to withhold aid to
Ukraine now he was asked what reasons he
was given for withholding aid from
Michael Duffy who was a trump appointee
at the Office of Management and Budget
we now have the deposition it just came
out and sandy recalls that the president
was concerned quote about other
countries not contributing money to
Ukraine that the reason for the
withholding of aid was because as
president from pecet from the beginning
he didn't want to contribute aid alone
he wanted other countries to chip in as
well no word of a quid pro quo I think
that's why the Democrats dumped this
deposition right before Thanksgiving
when no one's paying attention speaking
of bad news for Democrats as
Thanksgiving Elizabeth Warren Elizabeth
Warren always has a tough time on
Thanksgiving it brings back bad memories
for her she got some more bad news her
poll numbers are collapsing she went
from 28 percent in Quinnipiac slashed
poll of the Democratic primary that's
good enough to be the top of the pack to
14 percent half of her support is gone
now that's just one poll but that's the
poll that we've got why is it it's
because Americans hate her health care
plan you can see that in the cross tabs
she may have doomed her candidacy very
very sad news for her but something to
be thankful for all of us we'll get to
the mailbag first we got to say goodbye
to Facebook and YouTube and I have to
tell you right now go to daily wire calm
and do not purchase a membership to
daily wire
do not purchase why not is this my final
stand am I just gonna walk out of here
kick in Bend the studio door and say I'm
out of here I don't want anyone to buy a
subscription to the daily wired no
that's not what I'm saying at all but
you should not buy a membership today
why because I have gotten word who daily
wire they are going to be running some
incredible deals on Black Friday and I
don't want you to go there now and spend
all your money and then in two days
figure out that you could have saved a
lot of money I'm talking about
incredibly good deals I'm talking about
could bankrupt the company deals with
that means for you as you should wait
until good darkus Friday you should wait
until Black Friday to join and then you
will reap the amazing rewards I'm
telling you you won't be disappointed
the amount of money that you can save on
Black Friday is wild so make sure you
wait until Black Friday and then buy
your membership Sam we've got a lot more
coming up in the mailbag head on over to
daily wire comm and then just wait until
Black Friday we'll be right back
all right first question from Calvin hi
Michael you mentioned in a tweet a few
weeks ago about how Catholics shouldn't
practice yoga since it is part of the
Hindu religion why is that if it's just
meditation and poses I'm not sure it
actually poses a threat to the Catholic
faith but I trust your insight and
judgment on the subject sure things not
just the Catholic faith but
Protestantism and other faiths as well
if yoga were just about stretching out
your body that would be perfectly fine
if it were a neutral sort of meditation
that would be fine you could do it that
does exist that is called Pilates yoga
is something different Yoga involves
aspects of Eastern religion so there are
all these various religious things to
come with it
the ohms and the aahs and the various
salutations to various sort of Eastern
ideas and religious concepts so it's
very bizarre that people do that and I
have friends of mine who say that going
to yoga like that for them is like going
to church that's true in a secular
society anything you do that's even
vaguely spiritual would be a substitute
for church there's nothing wrong with
stretching your body I don't do it
because I don't really enjoy physical
exercise but there's nothing wrong with
you stretching your body or engaging in
meditation I strongly recommend
meditation I more strongly recommend
prayer and I especially like the Rosary
so there certainly plenty of options
here for that
but if you're going to engage in prayer
and meditation and contemplation and you
are not a Hindu or let's say you are a
Christian I would just recommend doing
it in a Christian way and if you want to
stretch your body just stretch it out
and do Pilates but I think the for what
many people in the West engage in as a
sort of pseudo spiritualism of yoga is a
poor substitute for religion and it gets
you involved in certain theological
concepts that but just don't don't go
along with your estate and religion okay
John liberals make the argument that we
should ban guns because people may be
killed
conservatives make the argument that we
need to strengthen our borders because
people may be killed what do you think
is the best argument to differentiate
between these two Thanks
I agree that that's the argument the
Liberals make for banning guns but I
don't think that's the argument that the
Conservatives make primarily for the
border it's a secondary argument it is
true killers and drug dealers and people
like that will cross the border if it's
porous but the primary argument
conservatives make for closing the
border is that it's the law illegal
immigration is illegal it's not that
complicated and a country has a right to
decide who comes and who goes and a
country has a right especially in
self-government to decide who gets to
use its resources who gets to vote
prints elections and who gets to to be
here who gets to be part of that society
conservatives go wrong when we primarily
make utilitarian arguments you know a
good example of this is on socialism
you'll sometimes hear conservatives say
socialism is bad because it doesn't work
people don't have a lot of money under
socialism sure that's all true feel free
to make that secondary argument
socialism is wrong because it's evil to
quote pope leo xiii it's a pest it's a
plague it tries to steal the very gospel
itself to quote Winston Churchill it's
the gospel of envy and the creed of
ignorance it is intrinsically wrong bad
evil
that's why socialism is so bad because
it deprives you of your own property it
deprives you of your heirs an agency
deprives you of your own freedom also
it's very inefficient also people will
have less money everybody will have less
money under socialism but you got to
make the essential argument first
because if you make the utilitarian
argument then you're arguing on the
left's premises and then you're going to
end up in the sort of confusion where
you're you're doing leftist calculus and
he'll end up at leftist policy solutions
from oh Michael I see this push for
anyone being able to go into whichever
locker room depending on if you feel
like a man or a woman at that time do
you think it will push in the direction
of simply having co-ed restrooms and
locker rooms thoughts yes it probably
will if that is gross gross things
happen in bathrooms I don't want ladies
around well men are doing limit I don't
want men around while
ladies are doing them it's just yucky
it's gross we should be civilized come
on people we're not animals you don't
have men and women's restrooms for pigs
you don't have men and women's restrooms
for cows you do for people because we're
humans were civilized have some dignity
but we are probably moving that
direction we've been moving in that
direction for decades initially you had
the unisex bathroom unisex that term
doesn't make any sense because there are
two sexes but we've had unisex around to
all our lives then now you have the
gender-neutral bathroom if it's a single
restroom this makes perfect sense but
what's happening now increasingly
especially in even high-end places is
you will have one generic restroom with
individual stalls gross and people get
rid of urinals in those restrooms
because there's a war on masculinity of
manliness so there's no no urinals at
all it's a very bad idea
men and women are different we should
enjoy those differences sexual
difference makes the world a lovely
place
Viva native Holmes from Scott dear
Michael I was recently invited to go
hunting for deer with a friend I have
always found that prospect intriguing
and I agree with many of the points in
the pro hunting debate but I also
understand the case that anti hunters
make I'm interested in seeing what your
view is on this topic especially when it
comes to Christianity my fiance and I
love your show Thanks I don't understand
the case that anti hunters make so I
would love you to enlighten me on this I
guess the case the people who don't like
hunting make is that we shouldn't eat
animals because if you go out and hunt
your own food it is much more ethical
than partaking in factory farming if
you're gonna make an ethical argument at
all certainly it's the case that killing
an animal in the wild is nicer for that
animal than just raising it on a factory
farm where it can barely move around so
then the argument becomes about eating
meat is it wrong to eat meat
no it's not we can tell from nature from
our own bodies that we were made to eat
meat our bodies function much better
when we eat meat human beings thrive
when we eat meat also animals aren't
people this was the topic of my show
yesterday
we anthropomorphized animals we now
treat animals better than we treat
people in many instances I mean now it's
a federal offense to kick a puppy but
you could kill a human baby at virtually
any point of development anywhere in the
country without any issue and if you
kill a human being
it's a state-level crime not a federal
crime some people say well it torturing
animals is evidence that you'll grow up
to be a serial killer
sure but you kick the puppy you get a
federal offense if you start killing
people it's a state crime we've totally
inverted this animals are not people
human beings have intellect and will
animals do not they have their own sort
of vague shade of intellect they're not
totally inanimate objects but they don't
have free will in the way that we do
they don't have dignity in the way that
we do we should be stewards of animals
we should be kind animals we should
never abuse animals because it dulls our
own humanity it's so undignified it's so
cruel and that reflects poorly on us but
we should not extend to them rights they
are animals they are made to be eaten
and they are very very delicious from
Scott when it comes to Hong Kong I know
left-wing sports reporters are excusing
NBA woke jerks like Steve Kerr Greg
Popovich and LeBron James for supporting
China but I want to know is there any
truth that the Hong Kong protests are
merely about the extradition of a man
who murdered someone in Taiwan
thanks nope it's about China clamping
down on possessions that it does not
have total control over don't forget
Hong Kong was ruled by the British until
1997 I think it was 1997 or 1999 at that
point it reverted back to the control of
China this was a very sad day certainly
for Hong Kong but for the whole world
since then China has been trying to
encroach on various territories that are
around it than it doesn't have total
control of they've been trying to make
incursions into the South China Sea they
they want to grow they are on the rise
their economy is exploding they're in
the WTO the World Trade Organization
they are posing a major threat to the
United States we should oppose them it's
not the Cold War anymore Russia is not
our number one geopolitical foe it's not
right
after 9/11 anymore the Middle East is
not our number one geopolitical foe
whether that be in the Taliban in
Afghanistan or Saddam Hussein who no
longer exists it's China China is our
number one geopolitical foe we should
treat them as such and those
little-little Quisling was over in the
NBA our are ashamed to to sporting and
also to the United States final question
from Benedict Michael Brickhouse Knowles
can you please give some commentary on
Elizabeth Warren saying she prefers
Netflix and chill over Broadway and
dinner I feel it says a lot about our
current culture and politicians
willingness to pander it does obviously
she's quite a panderer she pretended to
be Native American to get professional
advantage for 30 years but that does say
a lot I think most people prefer Netflix
and chill over Broadway and dinner
Broadway and dinner is better Netflix
and chill is lazier it's more slothful
it's Dumber it's it's more about the
self it brings you into yourself more
because you don't have to leave your
couch Broadway and dinner brings you out
into society
you see people you interact with other
people you see a new show live theater
conveys more than television does you
then maybe go get a drink afterward and
talk about the show it's much bigger and
life is big life flourishes when life is
big we have made everything just about
ourselves and when it's not just
ourselves it's our partner next to us
who comes over in Netflix and chill and
usually they don't even watch the movie
that much if you know what I'm talking
about
it's it's our life now is about our
screens
it's about hunched over looking at these
tiny little screens it should be big the
world is a big beautiful place life was
more beautiful when you would go to
Broadway and dinner rather than just
Netflix and chill because Netflix and
show by the way also just means go have
sex sex is a great thing but it's not
all there is in life but it's all we
want to focus on we should open
ourselves up to the beauty of our
country or the beauty of the world and
the grandness of life maybe we'll be
able to do that and give thanks for that
tomorrow on Thanksgiving in the meantime
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
nul show see you then
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boy
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis clever
and our technical producer is Austin
Stephens assistant director pavel why
douse key edited by danny D'Amico audio
is mixed by mike core amina hair and
makeup is by Jessa alvera and our
production assistant is Nick Sheehan the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19 if
you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle well tune into the
Ben Shapiro show we'll get a whole lot
of that and much more see you there